I'm thrilled on behalf of the the team
at Massif and the teams that are working
on the division worldwide to exclusively
announce to our community first that
we're working on the sequel to the
division the division - on the state of
the game the developers finally
confirmed what we've all been
speculating over for quite some time now
that the division 2 is currently being
worked on in fact they've had a small
team working on it since about a week
after the original game was released
they said in the state of the game that
the main concept of division 2 has been
in planning and development since April
2016 there has been a lot of discussion
over a sequel versus just continuing to
add updates to the game particularly
after destiny - crushed so many dreams
but the game director and creative
director stated that with so many
stories and experiences we want to
explore and felt that a sequel is the
best way to investigate these stories
I'm gonna go out there and say that
creating a sequel for the division is a
good call the main reason for this being
is that over the last couple of years a
number of really cool ideas to be thrown
out there both for quality of life
updates and new content to be added but
because of how the original game and
coding has been set up they've limited
to themselves and what can be added
without starting from the bottom up it's
not like they're starting from scratch
they have a good model to work off but
it could mean that we'll start to see
some of the things that we've been
asking for over the last two years like
a better user interface and maybe even a
decent API to work with so we can
finally have that companion app we've
been screaming out for and on the other
side it's a lot more difficult getting
people to join a game of this nature
when it's already been out for a couple
of years particularly with the divisions
rocky start a lot of people have already
written the game off a new title is more
likely to grow the community in my
opinion Ubisoft as well with sequels in
most cases building on what already
works and cutting out what doesn't and
when are we getting the division - well
they're not saying right now if I had to
guess I would say we're likely to see it
in the first quarter of 2019 partially
because of how they've planned the next
few updates and partially because I
think they want to have it up about the
same time or before anthem comes up
either way though we aren't going to
hear any more about the division - until
June
at e3 2018
does this mean that the division is dead
now no not at all in fact they've
actually announced a couple more updates
one point eight point one to be released
in April and one point eight point two
in June with update one point eight
point one we'll get to more legendary
missions to add to the mix Amherst
apartment and Grand Central Station
we'll also be getting two new global
events with unique modifiers and masks
to collect global event 5 blackout will
be out in April global event six
onslaught in May as announced in the
state of the game a few weeks ago
they're working on improving and
increasing the drop rates for classified
pieces these changes will also be
implemented with update one point eight
point one if you don't know what the
changes were drop rates of classified
items from bosses has been increased to
6% from 3% the mission reward of
legendaries now have a 20% chance to
drop a classified item season past
supply drops have a 10% chance to drop
classified item and during global events
there are now caches that are targeted
at the classified gear sets depending on
which global event is playing season
past supply drops now give a hundred
division tech daily assignments give 25
division tech and weekly assignments
give a hundred division tech you can now
farm all exotics from the light zone
bosses all vendor exotics have been
removed from the loop pool so if like me
you're sick of picking up the cassadee
every time you get a weekly cash you'll
no longer have to worry about this also
in the next update the division will get
the Xbox one X patch that we've been
waiting on for so so long as we speak
there's another pts running to test out
the new global events and legendary
missions that will be added soon the pts
will stay open for two weeks and is only
available on PC
update 1.8 point 2 is a bit smaller than
the one we're getting next month with
this update we'll be getting to more
legendary missions missions to be
announced and the shield update shield
should be interesting
the idea behind it is that through
completing achievements in Division one
we should earn rewards that will be
presented to us in the division - I
imagine these will be similar to the
commendation system the rewards are
likely to be cosmetics and patches but I
think this will be a great way to keep
players in the game and towards the
division to launch especially if you're
a completionist like me who wants no
needs to collect everything a possible
again so these updates aren't going to
bring as much content as one-point-eight
did but it's nice to see that even after
announcing that they haven't just
dropped all support towards the original
game
I've added the division 2018 roadmap to
the end of the video it shows a lot of
what I've covered here take a screenshot
otherwise I've left a link in the
description below in preparation of
picked myself up a PC copy of the game I
just want to keep my options open on
launch day but my god I really need some
practice it's been a while since I
played a game of this nature on PC I
really need to work on the muscle memory
this info is a few days old now and I
apologize for not getting it out earlier
real life keeps getting in the way of my
gaming I know there are a lot of you who
don't look on Reddit every day so
hopefully this has been some news for
you guys as well as my usual build or
theory crafting content I do plan on
covering a bit more in the way of news
related pieces on things like the
division to but also other looter
shooters coming out in the future such
as anthem guys and girls I can't forget
about the massive female following I
have let me know if this is the sort of
thing you'd like to see from me in the
future also if you have any key binding
tips let me know I could use all the
help I can get otherwise Cheers
you
[Music]